ναφυπουργία θλητισμού με ένανα κάθεται σε κείνη την καρέκλα για παραδειγμα όου απλοσκοντίης τελευταία το
λιμπιάδα τα επομένατασισρα χρόνια ξέρει των αθλητισμό έρει της σημαίνει κίνη τρογαος αθλητές ίσωσ χώρά
μας είναι καιρός να ποκτήσει αυτόν το εφυπουργείο ι είναι κτι που φαίνεται ότι θα
γίνει το έχουνέχουν επί καισυμφωνόσέα πυ εί είναι αναγγίων να γίει πρόσφαταείχαμε μπάει στη βουλή
μετά τους ολιμτερακούσα αγόνες και συζητουσάμε εντρόπους βελτίωσεις και συντέτεμα αυτό που λέγαμε πρι με
το σύστημα με το να διαλέξεις πθε να επεντήσεις κάτι που έχω οποί είναι ότι
πρέπει να γίνει μια επιτροποή διαφορειτική για για τους ολυμπιονκες γι αυτούς που έχουν εβάλει
διαούς και διδικιτιγούν τα απαξανά ένα πολύ απλων παράδειγμα πάτε που εγκριον να πτη βουλή
συνηθώ γίνεται πελιωςσμάιος έρχομαστε νιούνιων οι αθριτές δεν ιαμονότιλπιακή χρόνιά που κάνουν πρέθεημάσεις παναγόνες αυτό
εί κάτι που είναι κάθε χρόνο το ίδι και είνεται α χρόνια μεγάλες οι χωρές
έχουμε να πάζεται τρ τία στο οποίο μέχρι το τέλος ας πούμε τώρα του κοτέα
θα το έχουν για τους επόμενος ολιπιακούς το κάθε άθυμα θα ξένα ακριβώς πωςα κατομύρια
θα πάρει για να μπορεί να τα ταξυνομίσει ναεπεντήσει να σκεφτεί για τα λοιπά δηλάμε
για κατομύρια χώρα μας ζύνητος πάσει παδερεί να το θέματόπως είναι αυτό που ιόιδιαχείρηση είναι
μπορύ σεμαντικό δηλαδη όμως αυτά τα δέκαδεκαπέτ άτομα που θα είν σε αυτό οείναι ολιμπιαγίνομάδα
ναστύνω να μάσουμε ννα μην κάτε χρονο να περιμένουν να θεοιούνις να του πουν να
ατελικά φέατος θα παριστόσα ι πολλές φορές να ξωτεψουμε τα χρήματα ν ρθύν να μας
τα καμορίπές να μας τα αποκαταστήσουν μετά από ποδείξεις ενά υπάρχει ένα πράμ από πριν
ότι αυτά είνετα χρήματα για όλινδιόμαδα αν είναι και πού πιο εύκολον α γίνει α
σωστς ιόσως στος προχραμματισμός καιιπλητές να φωσιωότιπρέρά των αθλητών